so a few years ago my girlfriend and I
we decided to go see a movie downtown
and for some idiotic reason we decided
to buy one of those giant buckets of
toc1 and I actually ended up eating most
of not all of it before the movie had
even started so stupid decision and I
guess you could say that's where the
real drama begins after the movie ends
were walking to the car and I just feel
sick but I'm able to fight that off we
think you know what it's 25 minutes so
we get home it's not really going to be
a problem so we get into the car and
we're driving and all sudden the popcorn
of my body just decides to change
direction towards the poop realm and I'm
not going to share this with my
girlfriend so I just keep it to myself
my body is just rigid with tension
trying to hold this in so we're driving
and we just run into a giant wall of
bumper-to-bumper traffic I think oh my
god this is the end my girlfriend can
clearly sense that something is wrong so
she looks over at me and calmly but
blatantly just goes do you have to poop
and our relationship wasn't necessarily
at poop status yet but I just kind of
looked straight forward and just said
yep we think okay you know what our best
option is probably to take the next exit
whatever it is however the next exit
that was coming up was just a really bad
neighborhood but we decided you know
what that's what has to happen so we get
off the exit and I'm driving like Jason
Bourne I'm just weaving in and out of
traffic and we make a turn and I can see
there's a is in the distance and I think
oh my god salvation but then this really
fast thought process just Rockets
through my head and I think no this
can't be an option because if you go in
there and there's someone in the
bathroom or they're cleaning it or it's
locked whatever the reason you're going
to poop your pants in front of 30 plus
people in a bad neighborhood so all
those kind of mark off the checklist
this isn't going to work and it just
decided you know what gametime decision
let's drive my car over the sidewalk and
just behind this abandoned factory
building I scamper out of this car like
a wild animal
I run behind a dumpster and I just [ __ ]
my brains out I've never felt lower as a
human being in my entire life but the
next step now is how do I clean myself
up so I ditch the underwear use that as
the paper and I'm looking around for
what else I can use and think no you're
behind an abandoned Factory you don't
need a tetanus shot in your [ __ ]
so that's not going to be an option so I
pull my pants up I kind of wobble back
to the car my girlfriend is hysterically
laughing this entire time and I'd
cleaned out my car the day before so
there was nothing I can use napkins
paper towels nothing but there were a
Google map direction so I decided to use
those go back behind the dumpster clean
myself up as best as I can to that point
get back to the car I'm smelling
terrible continue our drive home
eventually we make at home I take a
shower I'm back to a full human being
status and for the rest of that day and
into the night this thought process that
just kind of lodged itself in my brain
was what if someone goes behind that
dumpster and they see this just mess of
just human food everywhere and they
think oh my god who did this what kind
of disgusting monster is responsible for
this and then his partner I guess picks
up a piece of paper and says here's his
google map directions his address is
right here let's go get him and I that
doesn't make any sense but that's what I
had in my head so needless to say I was
never held accountable for my actions so
that is good and I'm proud to say that
the brave lady in that story is still my
girlfriend today and I would say that
who brought us closer together